responsive patterns are quickly evolving
but there are a handful of established
patterns that work well across pretty
much any device most patterns use by
responsive web pages can be categorized
into one of four patterns mostly fluid
column drop layout shifter and off
canvas in some cases a page may use a
combination of patterns for example
column drop and off canvas in each of
these examples and the examples moving
forward the colored boxes represent
areas of content let's break them down
one by one I'm going to show you how
these patterns work and then using your
flexbox skills and media queries you're
going to practice implementing them